foreign
I'm good how are you
you know what I've got a lot to be
thankful for live and blessed living
blessed oh that means something's a
disaster
whenever somebody deflects like I'm
mostly great that's awesome yeah what's
up it sounds better than I'm horrible
right it may be a little less less a
little more disingenuous but yes it does
sound better what's up
so I got a little bit of a question for
you today and I'm just going to kind of
start with a question and then sort of
fill in the Gap
um
my husband and I are really struggling
with physical intimacy
um I really we're just it's not working
it's not going well we're not connecting
um there's a lot of background to that
we've been married for 15 years
we have six children our oldest is 13.
the youngest is almost two
um when the baby was four months old I
discovered that he had gone and gotten
of affecting me without my knowledge
um that was
a real game changer for me I was not
ready
to call that yet
um I have loved being a mother
it's sort of been my whole life and so
it just threw me for a tailspin
since then our marriage has just kind of
Tanked to be honest we have just not
been doing well at all feels like we've
sort of hit rock bottom and I feel very
stuck and I'm just wondering if you
could
give me some insight maybe some advice
so that doesn't happen in a vacuum
right I would be stunned if he had not
had conversations about if y'all had not
talked about this is enough this is too
many or when you got pregnant again and
number six and he started struggling or
number five
that's a strange bold move just to do
out of left field with no warning no
conversation
there had been conversations I had
repeatedly said I am not okay with that
particular option I'm not okay with that
um we had explored other options and
even tried some different things and
um yeah number number six was a surprise
um I was not expecting to get pregnant
again
um but
I did know he was getting done and he
did know I wasn't there so it didn't
completely come out of the blue
okay
so
the only way I know how to answer some
of these questions that I know are going
to get me in trouble no matter what I
say is just to give you what's
um was just right at the top of my soul
right now is that okay
yes please so
um
I believe strongly that when people when
couples get married when you say I'm all
in on you and you're all in on me that
we make decisions like this together
mm-hmm so
it like to flip things around gender
wise and see how does it play on the
other side
I'm trying to imagine a guy calling in
saying I told my wife that she's gonna
and she went and
had a hysterectomy or some sort of
procedure and she hysterectomy as a
whole you can't hide that one but
um went and had a procedure done and my
first thought would be hey dude that's
her body
like if she doesn't want to go through
all of that again
and so I'm flipping that around and I
know childbirth is in incredibly
different for a woman's body than a
man's body
but I have to say it had to have been a
nuclear option for him to do that
like there had to be like he knew going
into that I'm going to blow up
everything and it's worth it because I
can't keep doing this
and whenever somebody does that I guess
I just um maybe this is a fault of mine
but I get real empathetic really fast to
think what must have same as if
somebody's like like struggling with
alcohol my first thought is I can't
believe you're drinking my first thought
is my God what has happened in your life
that the only way you can get through a
day is like this
and so I have to ask and I'd love to
have I'd love to talk to him I'd love to
ask like dude what was happening in your
life that you knew I might blow up
everything
but I cannot do another kid
I can't I'm out I've lost my wife I've
lost my home I've lost I'm scared of
finances whatever the thing is that just
feels like such a nuclear option so I
guess for both of you my shoulders drop
and my hope would be
that after 15 years and six kids
y'all have been through a lot of ups and
a lot of downs that when somebody pulls
a nuclear option like that that is not a
everybody goes running for the hills but
it is a
whoa whoa whoa what just happened here
and it brings you closer together
at least maybe not closer together but
at least brings you to the table
for you to say was I that bad
or was I that unreasonable or maybe I
didn't hear you right
or we have to reimagine our life now
because I imagine it's with eight kids
and you just you just set the nuclear
option right and so right I get it's a
major it's a such a violation
and at the same time it's such a
violation that I'd have to say something
else in that in that ecosystem is just a
mass my guess is your marriage has been
struggling for a while is that fair
that's totally fair
So when you say it's just kind of Tanked
and bottomed out what does that mean
do you hate him are you so mad and
enraged that you can't be around him or
is he so ashamed at what he did like
tell me where that where that bottoming
out is is happening
hold on but but everything after that is
all the causation is a choice
so yes it happened it didn't make you be
mean to him and it didn't make him hide
in shame and it didn't make you not want
to sleep with him anymore and it didn't
make him not want to sleep with you
anymore all those are choices y'all have
made on the back end of this nuclear of
him pulling the pin right
so what are some choices y'all have made
on the back end that have just continued
to spiral this thing out
I I think it's
voices of like well where do we go from
here I feel like I've been betrayed he
feels betrayed I feel like trust is
broken he feels like trust is broken how
do we rebuild this and
um and then it's all about sort of
closing in on each individually like
well I need this well I need this and
you weren't giving it to me and I'm I'm
not getting it now and
is the back and forth um and we cannot
seem to get to a place where we can move
forward from here
and I don't know how to
let go I feel stuck I I don't know how
to let go of the resentment the anger
the hurt
what is anger and resentment getting you
right now
because it's playing it's Play It's
serving a purpose it's playing a role
what's it get getting you right now
maybe in some weird way
it's it's still
means that
my opinions in place
because I felt like
be completely disregarded how I felt
about this I don't think so I think he
absolutely took into consideration your
opinion
I think what you can't rest wrap your
head around is you didn't get your way
okay and that's a totally different
thing
you tell me
you've got six beautiful kids you have a
family of eight
you had a picture where it's gonna be a
family of 10 or a family of nine that
picture's now gone
so you tell me what comes next
do you simmer in anger and resentment
and despair
or do you sit down with your husband and
say
like
it was so important for me that we have
more and you violated that and you snuck
around me and did it and he says I know
because you wouldn't hear me out
and then you both say will you build
something completely new from the floor
up with me
that's the only way forward there is no
going back there's no going backwards to
this like I don't know maybe you could
get it reversed
so are you just saying lots of feelings
out and no just not go there no I don't
know what to do with the feeling I'm
saying you have
you have changed yourself chained
yourself you have hitched yourself to
your feelings
foreign
s are very very important but they often
lie to us and they don't tell us the
truth
they are not not feelings are not truth
tellers it's not their job their job is
to get our attention
okay and so your body may feel like I
hate that guy and that's why challenging
those feelings writing them down and
challenging them do I really hate that
guy no but I'm really really heartbroken
in what he did
and grief demands a witness
I don't think you've grieved this I
think you're at War
and again let me say this if he was on
the phone I would say dude what were you
doing
but he's not on the phone so I can only
talk to you and what you're doing is
you're poisoning your home hoping it
kills him but it's killing you
yeah
and affecting our children and just the
whole environment absolutely is this a a
deep betrayal yes
is it also his body yes is that make
this super messy yes
but it sounds less like he didn't listen
to my opinion it sounds more like I
didn't get my way
and
that turns it into uh he won and I lost
and I don't lose not in my house
and I'm just gonna tell you that that
that attitude in a marriage is a recipe
for this thing ends
and you end up with as a single mom with
six kids
yeah I don't want to go there I know you
don't
but also
if you don't want to go there you have
to put in the work to
build something completely new
so before this happened after kid three
or after kid four what was the
challenges in your marriage
um finances were a challenge
um
just both of us have strong Wills I so
conflict was present all the time I tend
to withdrawal in Conflict so nothing
ever got resolved I would just withdraw
when conflict showed up and um we would
never actually get any of our issues
worked out everything got shoved under
the rug
that was just a tip of the iceberg
is there a chance that he was just a
prop in the world that you wanted to
create for yourself
I've never thought of it that way but
maybe often when other people are
playing a part in our picture
of our life
when they don't do what we want them to
do as a part of that picture
we don't we go to war we don't have a
because it's not building something
together it is no it's Christmas is
going to look like this
if you don't do Christmas like this then
I'm gonna withdraw I'm gonna fight you
to the death because Christmas looks
like this in my freaking picture
and that happens over what time we leave
for church and happens over what we have
for dinner when you're going to be home
and what this looks like and how our
kids are going to be because I could see
on this side of it
um if y'all are up till midnight
stressed about finances
and you want to bring four or five more
kids into this thing I could see that
not computing
and also the rational part doesn't well
but I can also see you wanting four more
kids and he's out buying four-wheelers
and boats and whatever and you're like
well if you weren't buying stupid stuff
then
we could afford this big beautiful
family
but it sounds to me like he's a prop
in I will have 10 kids or I will have
eight kids or even more than that I'll
get whatever I want because it's my life
and his job is to give me what I want
and if he you happen to be a prop in his
life
or if he's just tired of trying to build
something together because there is no
together because it's going to be
elsewhere or no way
or she just withdraws and disappears
see what I'm saying how can I change
that if that's who I am how I don't know
I don't you just made that an identity
and I don't I'm not gonna I don't want
you to to do that I don't I'm not gonna
let you get away with that at least on
the phone call
I think you're probably a great mom
and I think you can you have been a
great wife in Seasons especially
I think you are so exhausted
that you don't know what day it is
and I think your body is so desperate
for connection and your way to get to
connection is to control every single
variable on the planet
is that fair
yeah I'm definitely somewhat of a
control freak yeah I only know that
because your husband went and did
something crazy
that's Madness right going to get a
vasectomy without even telling your wife
yeah I I don't even know how that would
be possible
I mean I know how it would be possible
but like even after care and stuff I
just don't understand I can't wrap my
head around that
But ultimately I think you have to get
to a place where I am going to
well let me back up you have to decide
my marriage
to this man
is worth more than me my pseudo fake
pretend control over every variable
you have six kids there's gonna be
variables shooting all over the place
that's six different girlfriends and
boyfriends and six different so I don't
want to date anybody's in six different
struggling in different classes that's
six different car insurances and
colleges six different there's gonna be
variables everywhere
more than I will control I'll shut the
system down and if I don't get control
I'm going to take control in the one
down position I'm just going to withdraw
and go fine if you just want that I'll
just leave then
more so than that you gonna want
connection which means you're gonna have
to choose vulnerability which means you
have to risk getting hurt
and the irony is the more you try to
control the more you are guaranteeing
you get hurt
because at the end of the day people
don't like to be controlled and
eventually they go off and do something
insane
or destructive or they're so desperate
to feel alive or breathe they go do
whatever
so ultimately you have to sit down and
say not who's way who's getting whose
way
but you and your husband have to create
a home that worth living in
create a marriage worth staying in what
does that look like number one I will
refuse to be led around by the nose by
my feelings
I will say my feelings out loud I will
process them I'll have a counselor that
I talk to I'll have a couple of
girlfriends that I'll talk to I will
have a journaling practice that I will I
will commit to the end of time to write
down how I feel and then I will go do
the next right thing whether I feel like
it or not
I don't feel like being nice to him
because he made me what
how can I love you today
I don't feel like picking up the trash
after these dumb kids he's worked 14
hours today I'm gonna go pick up the
trash
I don't feel like exercising or I don't
feel like going to bed I want to watch
the show I will go to bed I'm gonna go
exercise I'm gonna go do what I need to
do
feelings are very important never smush
them down they will come out and they
will destroy everything and they don't
tell the truth that's not their job
their job is just to get your attention
to Signal something in this relationship
isn't okay something in this
relationship is not safe
Strangely I think the way forward is for
one of y'all to go first and since you
called me I'll suggest you if he had
called me I would suggest him
but it's a matter of going out to lunch
or going out to breakfast or going out
to dinner with no kids
and if you say well I can't leave my
kids that's problem number one
but you figure out how to pay for a
babysitter and you get somebody to watch
your kids or a neighbor to come watch
your kids
and you'll go out and you say for the
last 15 years I've tried to control
Every Breath You you take and I'm not
doing that anymore
and for the last 15 years every time I
didn't get my way I've pulled away I've
run from you because that kept me safe
as a kid I'm not doing that anymore and
I'm gonna have to practice I'll have to
learn how when I feel myself retreating
I'm going to stop it turn around and
come back in
because I love you that much
and then here's the kicker
would you promise to work on the things
that make it hard for me to be safe in
this home
because if he says no then what are we
doing
but if you go first
he may join you
and I would love it if you would have
him call me because I'd love to hear his
side of the story
but right now is not the time for
you should get that reversed or we're
now we're gonna have to go adopt now is
the time to stop everything and save
your marriage and you're not saving what
was the building has fallen it has hit
the ground and it has scattered
everywhere
you cannot sweep up all that glass and
steel and wood and smoke and rebuild
that building you got to build something
completely new
and it starts with one of you saying I'm
all in in these ways will you join me
and that's a scary scary thing to say
hang on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of building an unanxious life it
could be a road map for you and your
husband
what if we built a home that we both
liked being in that was loud in chaotic
because we have six kids but it was also
warm and filled with laughter and joy
and a lot of weird
um silly things that we do
and romance and sex again
what if we chose that life and we built
something new are you in
thanks for the call Elle I'm so sorry I
know it's a mess on a mess on a mess